Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sechste Ausgabe.
Das ist schon wieder so einiges passiert. Der Wochenrhythmus scheint gar nicht die schlechteste Wahl zu sein.
Nee, also bis jetzt haben wir, glaube ich, keine Probleme, Themen zu finden eher Probleme, Themen rauszuwerfen.
Ja ja, das äh war eigentlich auch so ein bisschen mein Verdacht. Das scheint sich jetzt zu bestätigen. Ähm legen wir doch einfach gleich los. Hier mit dem Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Ja genau, wir hatten das ja, also wir fangen ja mal an so mit Follow-Up Themen, über die wir schon gesprochen haben und da haben wir jetzt diese Facebook und FTC-Regelung. Die ist jetzt also äh irgendwie beschlossen worden. Da gibt's also ein.
Also vielleicht nochmal kurz zur Erinnerung, worüber wir da gesprochen hatten, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war das ja damals noch so ein bisschen so ein Gerücht, dass äh die FTC und Facebook sich da auf irgendetwas einigen könnten.
Genau.
Auf ihre Privatsphäre, et cetera.
Genau, also FTC ist dann hingegangen, es stellte sich dann raus, haben sie tatsächlich gemacht und haben äh Beschwerden gegen Facebook.
Also FTC Commission. Mhm.
Und haben äh Facebook vorgeworfen, dass sie äh Kunden getäuscht haben,
indem sie ihre Privacy Versprechen Privatsphäre, Datenschutzversprechen nicht gehalten haben. Und ähm da gab's also eine lange Liste an Beschwerden, dass sie irgendwann zweitausendneun die Friends-Liste
öffentlich gemacht haben ohne Vorwarnung und Widerspruchsmöglichkeit davor konnte man nicht sehen, wer mit wem befreundet ist auf Facebook,
sie dann irgendwie zweitausendneun veröffentlicht. Dann konnten Facebook Apps auf alle fast alle Daten zugreifen, obwohl das irgendwie,
äh laut AGB nicht vorgesehen war, ähm die Funktion, dass man etwas nur mit seinen Freunden teilt, konnte umgangen werden, wobei mir da jetzt unklar ist
in welcher Form das genau der Fall war. Wahrscheinlich, indem man irgendwie weiter teilt oder so. Wie gesagt, ich muss immer sagen, ich bin kein Facebook-Nutzer,
Dann waren die Facebook Apps nicht sicher.
Sinne von was?
Ähm ja ähm sie hätten also nicht äh also irgendwie.
Das getan, was sie versprochen haben, zu tun in Bezug auf die Privatsphäre.
Genau, waren also irgendwie offensichtlich waren die Sicherheitsprüfungen, die Facebook da angebracht hat, ähm nicht ausreinigt, könnte mir vorstellen, dass ich das auf diesen Fall bezieht, wo über Monate doch irgendwelche Facebook-Apps,
alle möglichen Daten irgendwie aus den Profilen abziehen konnten oder so,
denke, dass sich das darauf bezieht. Und ähm sie haben die Infos mit also Facebook hat Infos mit wärmenden geteilt, obwohl sie in den AGBs das Gegenteil versprochen haben. Das war, glaube ich, eine Liste mit insgesamt,
Ich habe sie nicht gezählt, aber eine ganze Menge.
Menger Beschwerden, die die FTC da so hatte und dann haben sie gesagt, und jetzt aber hier haben wir äh Druck ausgeübt auf äh Facebook und jetzt ähm,
wenn man einen Account gelöscht hat, dann gibt's spätestens dreißig Tage danach keinen Zugriff mehr auf diese Daten. Ähm,
und ähm innerhalb der nächsten hundertachtzig Tage wird's irgendwie eine unabhängige äh,
Untersuchung bei Facebook geben und dann wird diese alle zwei Jahre stattfinden für die nächsten zwanzig.
Ähm und da wird dann irgendwie geschaut von einer unabhängigen ähm von der unabhängigen Prüfungseinrichtung, ob,
ähm auf Facebook sich an die Regelungen dieser die Vorschriften der FTC jetzt irgendwie hält.
Also FTC stellt sich hin und sagt, ja hier, wir haben eine Menge Vorwürfe gehabt und Facebook ist eingeknickt. Während dann Mark Zuckerberg,
sein einen Blogpost schreibt und sagt, ja also
Privatsphäre war ja immer der Grundstein des Erfolgs von Facebook. Wir wollten diesen sicheren Bereich für euch schaffen im Internet. Leider dann haben wir ab und zu mal einige Fehler gemacht,
die größten Beschwerden dieser FT oder die größten Punkte dieser FTC Beschwerde hatten wir ja schon vorher längst selber ausgeräumt.
Und wir waren schon immer im Krieg mit Ozeanien.
Genau,
äh und ähm jetzt haben wir ich ich gebe euch hier zwei neue sheef privacy Officers. Also hat irgendwie zwei neue Leute eingestellt, die irgendwie dann für da zuständig sind und hoch in der Unternehmenshirachie stehen. Und dann eine lange Liste dazu
schrieben. Was schon alles verbessert wurde. Fand ich ganz interessant, wie also von von diesen beiden Seiten ähm diese Einigung dann.
Da
Gespinnt wurde. Aber wichtig ist halt jetzt, dass sie sagen, okay äh Facebook darf keine Änderung mehr machen, was die Privatsphäre Einstellung.
Betrifft, ohne die Leute vorher zu warnen. Und das wäre bei einer strengen Auslegung ja dann irgendwie diese Idee Opt-In. Ja.
Aber wenn man das jetzt so liest, was in dieser FTC Sache steht, kommt's mir irgendwie ich lese da nicht unbedingt heraus, dass äh Facebook eine weitere, also dass da steht, Facebook muss für die Leute auch weiter funktionieren, wenn sie nicht einwilligen. Also es scheint.
So wie ich das jetzt gelesen habe, ist die ist die Sache damit geklärt, dass Facebook vorher warnt, ja,
Also was sie sowieso in letzter Zeit ja dann schon irgendwie so gemacht haben. Also im Sinne von hallo, Freund, wir haben neue AGBs, äh willige doch mal bitte kurz ein.
So lese, so wie es alle machen, so wie sie, wie es sich irgendwie äh,
ähm wie es sich irgendwie gehört, aber es ist also nicht dieses äh kein es liest sich nicht wie eine Privacy Patty Fald
und ob in Lösungen, dass man also sagt, wir machen alles zu und bei allem, was du freigeben möchtest, musst du den Schalter selber drücken ähm und wir kommen nicht auf dich zu. Also das scheint es nicht zu sein.
Ich meine, das ist eine generelle Frage. Ähm.
Dieses, was bedeutet das, wenn man nicht der richtigen Meinung ist, heißt das, dass man dann sein Facebook-Account schließen müsste und man spielt nicht mehr mit. So, das würde ja de facto eigentlich,
ausschließen, dass äh irgendeine Änderung sich nicht durchsitzen ließe von Seiten von Facebook. Also,
Die was ändern wollen, kriegen sie's durch, auch wenn man offiziell einwilligen muss. Der einzige Vorteil, den man hat, ist, dass man
darauf hingewiesen wurde, aber man weiß ja, wie ausführlich solche äh
Konsumer Greenments so durchgelesen werden, bevor man da auf exakt macht. Das ist halt eher so ein störendes Fenster. Das muss jetzt schnell mal weg, damit man da äh schnell wieder an seine Sachen rankommt, ne. Aber,
Was ich jetzt interessant fand an dem, was du aufgezählt hast, ist ähm.
Wie hast du's formuliert, also in der dreißig Tage nach Accountlöschung wird was garantiert von Facebook.
Dass es kein Zugriff, dass sie keinen Zugriff mehr auf diese Daten ermöglichen. Also ich stelle mir das irgendwie so vor von anderen,
Also ich stelle mir das irgendwie so vor, ich mache irgendwie eine Facebook, ich habe irgendwie so ein Facebook-Ding und ähm dann mache ich dann lösche ich den Account, dann stelle ich mir das irgendwie so vor, dass es vermutlich nicht so war, wie gesagt, ich bin kein Facebook-Nutzer, dass dann.
Instantly, bei allen mein kompletter Stream irgendwie verschwindet. An Dingen, die ich da vielleicht irgendwann mal gemacht habe.
Und ähm wenn ich das jetzt so richtig, ich meine so einen Facebook-Nutzer, wir haben das ja schon gesehen mit diesen Profilen, die sich da einige Jungs dann, die haben sich ja ihre Daten da er klagt oder er, er
erfragt von Facebook, da ist ja eine ganze Menge drin. Und theoretisch, wenn ich sage, ich lösche meinen Account, muss ja alles weg sein. Also das äh weder darf da irgendwo stehen, dass ich irgendjemand auf dem Foto identifiziert habe, noch dürfen die Bilder drin sein, die ich irgendwann mal da
reingeladen habe und natürlich kann man sich ja vorstellen, dass in so einem Prozess irgendwo immer irgendwelche Schwierigkeiten gibt, sei es weil irgendjemand anders das Foto weiter geteilt hat,
Ja, ähm was ist dann mit dem, habe ich's dem dann geklaut oder konnte er das weiterteilen oder was auch immer, ähm ist er allgemein bekannt, dass.
Schon allein von der Struktur her mal nicht aus so einem, aus so einem Social Network irgendwie sinnvoll etwas wieder herauskriegen kann.
Ja, ist auch, dürfte auch sehr schwierig sein, es überhaupt aus Facebook herauszubekommen. Ich hatte jetzt im ersten Moment so gedacht, so, oh, sie sagen jetzt tatsächlich, wir löschen diese Daten. Davon kann ja wohl nicht die Rede sein, weil ich glaube.
Nee, das werden sie nicht machen. Also das.
Ja und vor allem das, selbst wenn sie das wollten, könnten sie das wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Zumindest nicht besonders effektiv im Hinblick gar nicht so sehr auf diese unglaubliche Replikation, die diese Daten erfahren, weil da könnte man natürlich auch eine Löschung replizieren, aber ich denke mir so Backups, die ist ja da sicherlich geben wird,
Nicht nachträglich um diese Datenbereinigung. Von daher ist ein Löschen in dem Sinne gar nicht möglich. Also es ist wird eigentlich immer nur so sein, dass man in so eine ewige Liste äh äh eintragen kann. Ach ja und diese Daten,
Bitte jetzt vergessen.
Also hier steht in dem äh.
Wortlaut ist äh,
time the diuser heißt Information exempt as require by Law und so weiter. Also irgendwie dreißig Tage nachdem du irgendwas weggemacht hast, muss Facebook dafür sorgen, dass keiner mehr darauf Zugriff hat.
Also es ist zumindest nach außen äh gegenüber anderen Benutzern oder eben äh Apps und dann mit irgendwelchen Firmen et cetera, dass es dann nicht mehr zu sehen ist, ne? Das ist ja auch schon mal was.
Ja mit den Apps und werbe, da hast du natürlich, das ist vielleicht der wichtige Punkt, dass sie dann, wenn du dreißig Tage nach dem du aus bist, auch nicht mehr die Daten, die sie irgendwann mal von dir hatten, weiter nutzen können, um irgendwie.
Tja, das wird sich äh sicherlich kaum machen äh lassen, weil wenn die Daten erst mal wechseln, sind die Daten weg. Aber zumindest liefert Facebook dann über diesen aktiven Kanal dieser Applikation äh,
Daten nicht mehr. Meine, das lässt sich gar nicht anders machen und in gewisser Hinsicht ist es ja auch richtig so, weil,
Bis dahin hast du ja, warst du ja präsent, du bist ja ein Facebook. Wenn du da bist, musst du einfach äh an den Gedanken gewöhnen, dass du da einfach einen Informations
Provider bist, äh deiner selbst und wenn das halt äh dann irgendwann nicht mehr dein Ding ist, okay, aber dann muss halt noch dreißig Tage warten und dann hast du zumindest diesen Fluss gestoppt oder hast zumindest
derzeit die Versicherung, dass dieser Fluss dann gestoppt sei, ob das dann wirklich so stattfindet, das äh wird dann interessant sein zu sehen, was diese Audits da bringen.
Aber äh man merkt zumindest, dass auch Facebook jetzt nicht mehr so beliebig agieren kann.
Genau, sie können nicht mehr beliebig agieren, aber andererseits irgendwie davon, dass sie jetzt von dem, dass sie jetzt datenschutzmäßig großartig einen auf die Nase bekommen hätten, kann man jetzt auch nicht sprechen.
Das kann man nicht. Na ja.
Sind mal gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt, aber ich denke, also irgendwas, was irgendwie wer auf privat oder gehofft hat, glaube ich nicht, dass dass das jetzt die Regelung ist, die diese Person irgendwie befriedigen wird.
Nach Deutschland, da war eine munteres Wochenende der Parteitage angesagt. Ähm es wurde allerlei getagt. Die SPD und die Piraten haben sich dasselbe Wochenende ausgesucht. Warum auch immer.
Ähm wir waren nicht da.
Wir waren nicht da. Wir waren weder bei der SPD noch bei den Piraten.
Leute waren da und es gab so für mich den Eindruck, dass ähm.
Einerseits, also wenn man jetzt erstmal uns auf die Piraten beziehen ähm
man allerlei Grund hatte, sich da gegenseitig die Eier zu schaukeln, nicht wahr? Viele Erfolge in diesem Jahr gelandet und äh
offensichtlich ist es auch gelungen den den störenden Streitlevel, der so üblicherweise auf den Parteitagen
Piraten herrschte äh ein wenig im Zaum zu halten und sich dann doch äh sehr um die eigentliche Programmarbeit zu kümmern,
Außerdem war mein Eindruck, dass die Netzthemen gar nicht so die Priorität hatten diesmal, sondern man war extrem bemüht, diesmal vor allem andere Themen auf den Tisch zu heben.
War's ja auch völlig in Ordnung ist. Also ähm,
Ich weiß ja nur, dass Geschrei war ja dann irgendwie groß, als dann irgendwann, also vor ein paar Jahren kriegten die Piraten die ganze Zeit auf die Nase, er, ihr seid ja nur so eine letzte Nischenpartei, sucht euch doch mal andere Themen. Jetzt machen sie andere Themen und dann gibt's irgendwie Beschwerden, dass sie sich nicht mehr um die Netzthemen kümmern würden. Also da
ja, ne. Also was soll ich dazu noch sagen? Also ich ich fand's also was man irgendwie gesehen hat, die die der Medienrausch,
der Piraten hat äh also hält an oder der oder der Piratenrausch der Medien hält an. Ja, du hast also es war irgendwie, ne, was haben wir da für für schöne Artikel.
Beides, beides, würde ich sagen.
Beides hält an. Die originellsten Anträge zum Piratenparteitag irgendwie macht das Handelsblatt irgendwie so einen Artikel
und dann irgendwie, ja, Piraten wollen, äh Drogen legalisieren, Piraten wollen Grundeinkommen und ähm die werden jetzt richtig ernst genommen und ähm
dieser Piratenparteitag, der muss, glaube ich, eine sehr, also, das scheint einfach eine sehr angenehme positive Veranstaltung gewesen sein. Was,
zu sein, was vielleicht nicht immer unbedingt bei Piratenparteitagen so war, dass sie so so von vorne bis hinten total Spaß gemacht haben.
Ich glaube, dass man sich jetzt auch ein bisschen beobachteter fühlt, das ist jetzt einfach nicht ausgeblieben. Vorher war's, glaube ich, vielen egal oder es wurde einfach so ignoriert und äh das mag auch,
so eine Änderung.
Im Verhalten mitgebracht haben. Ja, kann man jetzt sagen, okay, äh die Reihen geschlossen, lalala, ja, jetzt fangen sie genauso an wie die anderen Parteien auch. Da wird es sicherlich noch weit entfernt.
Nee, nee, aber gerade hier äh bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen, gab's ja auch äh große Debatten. Also was ich da gehört habe an Redebeiträgen, da gab's ja dann schon erbitterte Gegner und äh äh,
motivierte Befürworter und so, da gab's dann schon irgendwie.
Äh weil ich denke, jetzt steht die Partei auch am am Scheideweg. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite hat sich abermals nach, glaube ich, nach der Berlin-Wahl des Mitgliederaufkommen nochmal deutlich erhöht,
fünfzig Prozent nochmal zusätzlich, ich weiß es nicht genau.
So eine Zahl von neuntausend hätte ich gehört.
Auf jeden Fall
enorm, ja, wie viele äh neue jetzt dann auch gleich auf diesem Parteitag aufgeschlagen sind, keine Ahnung, weiß ich auch nicht, ob das äh bei der Piratenpartei überhaupt als Zahl erhoben werden darf,
Man scheint da ja so ein bisschen die Datensparsamkeit so ernst zu nehmen, dass man irgendwann über die eigene Basis keine Aussagen äh mehr machen kann. Also ich finde zum Beispiel dieses Ding mit
äh man weiß gar nicht, wie viel Frauenmitglied sind, das finde ich bisschen na ja, also.
Ich würde das schon wissen wollen, so, ja, um einfach mal auch,
an sich selbst da mal ein Fühler anlegen zu können, so äh was was ist denn die Realität? Ja, ich meine, auf der einen Seite wollen sie immer sachgemäße Politik machen und auf Basis von wirklichen Daten agieren, ja.
Aber dann haben sie irgendwie über sich selbst keine. Das äh finde ich, passt jetzt nicht so zusammen. Ja, ich verstehe zwar auch, was da die Motivation ist und so, aber scheint mir doch etwas bemüht zu sein. Aber was interessant ist mit diesem Grundeinkommen.
Ähm daran kann man, glaube ich, ganz gut festmachen, wie sehr jetzt eigentlich das Rennen losgegangen ist, um die Selbstbestimmung,
die nicht die Selbstverstimmung, sondern die äh Bestimmung des Selbst, also.
Wer sind wir eigentlich? Was, was, was wollen wir eigentlich? Bei dem Netz war das irgendwie relativ klar, wohin die Reise geht. Da mag's,
eben Unterschiede im Detail gegeben haben, ja, Urheberrecht so oder so und äh wie stehen wir denn jetzt nun zu dieser oder jenen
Variante von Vorratsdatenspeicherung vorschlagen et cetera aber im Wesentlichen war's klar und dann war man auch klar, warum man sich da einig ist, man ist ein Kind der Internetzeit und äh man hat
im Netz in den letzten zwanzig Jahren äh äh gelernt, anders äh Sachverhalte zu diskutieren, nicht unbedingt immer produktiver, aber auf jeden Fall anders. Und das wird dann halt
jetzt in der Piratenpartei gelebt und da ist man sich einig und alle haben einen Laptop auf dem Tisch und super. So, jetzt kommt's aber auf die
ganzen anderen Sachen an, wo sich, glaube ich, auch die unterschiedlichen Herkünfte der Mitglieder dann doch sehr deutlich zeigen werden und dass gerade beim BGE, beim äh also beim bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen, da kräftig gestritten wird
wundert mich an der Stelle überhaupt nicht, ja? Ähm mich ich weiß nicht, wundern ist es auch vielleicht das falsche Wort, aber ich habe äh zumindest.
Hätte ich das, hätte ich da jetzt nicht drauf gewettet, dass sie da jetzt eine Zweidrittelmehrheit durchkriegen dafür. Das ist ja äh passiert, ja, was auch immer das jetzt bedeuten mag und ähm jetzt wird sich einfach mal zeigen,
Wo diese Partei eigentlich wirklich landen wird.
Also meinst du quasi so diese diese Kernfindung, wie man irgendwie sagen kann, so die Rückbesinnung auf, weil sie die so die die SPD könnte sich, wenn sie wollte, auch irgendwie so Rückbesinnung auf sozialdemokratische Werte und die Grünen könnten sich auf.
Irgendwie eine Art von grünen Werten und du meinst jetzt quasi so die Findung der Piraten des Piratenkerns, der Piraten.
Ja klar, also was was will man eigentlich wirklich gesellschaftlich, ne?
Weil wenn man das jetzt so nach den Leuten, die wir kennen oder so oder nach denen, die jetzt in der Berliner Fraktion sind, äh versuchen messen zu wollen, das würde, glaube ich, nicht funktionieren,
Ja, das ist äh nicht so ganz klar. Man weiß nicht, was
was das Gesellschaftsbild ist, was eigentlich da der Konsens ist. Ich hätte auch vorher nicht sagen können, was in der Netzcommunity ja, wer auch immer das sein mag, äh für ein Gesellschaftsbild so vorherrscht. Grundeinkommen ist ja jetzt auch so eine Sache,
ähm.
Also ich bin mich da insofern outen, als dass ich das auch als eine ein äh eine sehr interessante, für eine sehr interessante Idee halte, ja? Mich aber auch gleichwohl nicht als kompetent,
ansehe
ähm das steuerliche und finanzrechtliche und sonstige wie rechtliche Geflecht der Bundesrepublik Deutschland oder gar Europas da so weit durchdrungen zu haben, um sagen zu können, so oder so realistisch ist es auf Basis des vorgeschlagenen Modells, so etwas auch tatsächlich umzusetzen.
Der anderen Seite denke ich mir, es ist auch erstmal viel wichtiger zu formulieren, was will man eigentlich, ja? Was wäre eigentlich die Lösung, die einem,
Am liebsten wäre und dann kann man das ja immer noch an die Realpolitik äh anpassen und an der Stelle finde ich das jetzt schon mal ein interessantes Statement, dass dass sie sich eben zu so einem Modell, was ja viel mit Solidarität äh zu tun hat. Ähm.
Entschieden haben.
Ja, also Grundeinkommen müsste man wahrscheinlich einen ganz eigenen äh Podcast zu machen.
Schon mal einen zu gemacht.
Ist aber dann länger her, oder?
Ja, ich habe im Rahmen von die Gesellschafter, die äh Produktion, die ich für Aktion Mensch gemacht habe, ich habe mich tatsächlich mit Gürz Werner unterhalten, der ja nun der,
Na ja, Mentor, Hauptmentor, eigentlich dieser Idee ist, der das äh am stärksten vertritt. Ich weiß nicht, ob er es jetzt also er hat es ja auch nur,
aufgegriffen, äh aber eben auch konkretisiert, insbesondere eben in dieser Variante bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen,
Und äh es steht da ja auch kräftig unter Beschuss, weil er ja auch von Anfang an sagt, die Finanzierung darüber muss eben über eine äh sollte über eine erhöhte Mehrwertsteuer äh fungieren.
Und zwar eine nennenswerte, ja, im bei Wegfall anderer Steuern et cetera. Also es ist schon extrem radikal, was er vorschlägt, ne? Und er hat ja da auch ein sehr anthroposophisch geprägtes Menschenbild, was damit äh verbunden ist, auch,
Auch wenn ich jetzt nicht sagen würde, die Piratenpartei gleitet in die andere ab. Das sicherlich nicht. Aber äh es ist äh ja auch romantisch, aber ich meine auch die die gesamte Idee des Sozialstaats äh ist ist romantisch,
Von daher finde ich da jetzt erstmal nichts Schlechtes dran. Also wer Lust hat, da äh mal reinzuhören, was der Gütz Werner dazu zu sagen hatte. Ich fand das schon sehr engagiert und sehr aufschlussreich.
Ist auf jeden Fall eine, also ist so eine so eine spannende Debatte. Was ich ganz interessant fand, vielleicht noch ähm,
Also es wird ja dann irgendwie als der Linksruck irgendwie äh gesehen, ne, aber das das stimmt ja eigentlich nicht unbedingt. Also die Idee eines Grundeinkommens ist nicht unbedingt eine besonders linke,
das wollte ich nur vielleicht nur kurz so mit auf den Weg geben. Es ist weder besonders äh kommunistisch noch sonst irgendwas, das ist eine ja, ist eine vielleicht eine vielleicht sozialdemokratische Idee, aber äh sie schafft auf jeden Fall nicht den ähm.
Sie schafft nicht den Kapitalismus ab oder so.
Eigentlich eher so eine vereinfachte, weil als was werden sie jetzt gerade bezeichnet die Piraten? Du hattest hier, wir haben hier gerade noch so ein Interview gesehen, sozialliberal, oder? Ist jetzt das, was was äh.
Sozial, ja oder linksliberal, je nachdem.
Ja, was so.
Liberal wird, glaube ich, dann auch selber gerne,
Ich denke, die Piratenpartei gefällt sich derzeit auch sehr, äh, in dieser Rolle des äh FDP Replacements. Ja, so nach dem Motto, wir stehen ja für das, für das die FDP früher mal vielleicht stand und äh jetzt eben versagt, dafür zu stehen.
Sehen sich da wirklich alle so? Ich glaube, es gibt ja auch ein paar.
Äh das glaube ich halt nicht, dass es äh alle so sehen.
Auch wenn's natürlich äh in der Netzgemeinde schon immer ähm sagen wir mal, äh immer schon viel mit der alten FDP romantisiert wurde und ja auch so Persönlichkeiten wie äh Sabine Leuthäuser, Schnarrenberger und äh Gerhard Baum et cetera ja auch,
Ja, bin ich Ikone, aber doch zumindest angesehene Persönlichkeiten äh sind, ja, die äh schon immer in der Lage waren, klare Gedanken zu formulieren und äh die dann auch politisch äh zumindest zu fordern, wenn nicht sogar umzusetzen.
Ja so und von daher hat man sich wahrscheinlich schon immer nach sowas,
im nach diesen Teilaspekt der FDP, also der Grundidee der der Freiheit aller äh gesehen hat, ne. Von der FDP ist halt dieses Wort Freiheit im Wesentlichen dann in Wirtschaftsfreiheit übersetzt worden mit der Zeit und das äh scheint so,
Piraten nicht zu fruchten.
Naja, also vielleicht können wir dann in der nächsten Woche, wenn äh sich da der Staub ein bisschen gelegt hat, nochmal nachlegen. Ich hatte jetzt keine Gelegenheit, die Streams zu verfolgen. Von daher äh.
Sehen wir einfach mal, was sonst noch so passiert ist. Aber es war ja auch die SPD unterwegs.
Und äh noch vor dem Parteitag gab's so tja aus SPD,
ja ist eigentlich ein SPD-Kind, ne? Kann man sagen, eine neue Gruppe, die sich gebildet hat, nämlich die D vierundsechzig.
D vierundsechzig, Bezug auf C vierundsechzig, aber dann Deutschland, also die deutsche C vierundsechzig Generation, hat sich äh zu einem,
formiert,
ganz interessante Sache auch, irgendwie, ja, ich wusste, dass da was kommen würde. Ich hatte vorher auch kurz mit äh Matthias Richel, der jetzt da der Vorstandsvorsitzende ist, darüber Kontakt,
Ähm Matthias Richel ist ähm vielleicht bekannt von diesem, das ist sozialdemokratisch DE und ähnlichen Sachen so um diese
Also um diese SPD Sache herum ist er da immer aktiv, der ist wenn man jetzt voll, hoffentlich kriege ich seine,
äh seine seine Berufsbezeichnung richtig hin, aber er ist so Kommunikationsstratege, so oder so PR äh Stratege oder sowas könnte man wahrscheinlich am ehesten sagen. Er hat ja wahrscheinlich auf dem auf der Seite von D vierundsechzig nochmal das richtige Wort für, aber so in in diesem Bereich ist er.
Also auf seinem Blog heißt es, Politik und anderes Dings.
Ja, das ist aber sein Privatblog.
Also auf jeden Fall ein ganz äh ganz äh fitter, aufgeweckter, junger Mann, der irgendwie ähm aus mir nicht ganz klaren Gründen ähm so irgendwie immer noch an diese SPD glaubt, ja, also der, der offensichtlich irgendwie ähm.
Wirklich die also mit diesem das ist Sozialdemokratisch, ja? Also quasi das da spricht ja schon so eine Enttäuschung heraus, so zu sehen, so diese Partei
vollständig von den Werten ab, die wir wollen, äh die, an die ich irgendwie glaube,
aber ich setze mit mit viel Arbeit und Fleiß und Mühe, eine Plattform auf, in der die Nutzer dann definieren können, was Sozialdemokratisch ist, um der Partei einen Spiegel der Basis wieder vorzuhalten, ja? Also, dass er so ein bisschen die Idee dahinter, ja? Und diesen Aufwand zu betreiben
ähm und nicht einfach zu sagen, ja gut, dann gehe ich halt zu einer anderen Partei. Fand ich schon ähm also es.
Der Junge äh ist äh leidensfähig so und dem scheint wirklich was an der an der SPD zu liegen. Ja, ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung so und dieses dieses, das ist sozialdemokratisch, das sind ja echt immer Dinge, die auf ähm,
auf großes Medien, auf große Medieninteresse auch so gestoßen sind oder oder Nutzerinteresse zumindest. Also genau da, Matthias Richel, fitter Mann, ist auch äh weiß nicht,
auch mal so im Umfeld von digitale Gesellschaft läuft man sich dann auch mal übern Weg. Ähm dann Nico Lummer.
Social Media Berater bei.
Und früher schon bekannt für seine Rolle in der SPD, äh als es noch diesen, wie hieß es, dieser Internetbeirat.
Gesprächsnetzpolitik oder äh nee, da hieß der noch Beirat.
Da ging's mir so um.
Oder digital Netzpolitik war, glaube ich, damals noch nicht das Wort. Der sich ja dann wegen dieser ganzen VDS-Geschichte auch aufgelöst hat, also wegen der.
Ähm, nee, was wegen Zensursula oder was wegen Speicher, jetzt komme ich ganz durcheinander. Ich glaube, das war im Vorfeld von der Zensursulageschichte, Netzsperrengeschichte haben sie sich aufgelöst. Sascha Logo war da ja auch mit dabei.
Online-Beirat der SPD, ja.
Online Beirat, genau, so hieß es. Und ähm ja.
Genau da, Nico Lümmer, ähm,
Ja, Nicoma, ähm Björn Böhning, Lars Klingbeil, SPD äh Politiker, Leonard Dobusch von der äh FU, der so im freien freien Netz und Creative Commons irgendwie ganz ähm.
Also bist aber jetzt bei Gründungsmitgliedern nicht nicht mehr nur bei dem äh Vorstand, ne?
Ja genau, ich gehe so ein bisschen, ich gehe so ein bisschen die Person durch unter den Mitgliedern, die mir.
Aber Matthias Richer und Richel und Niko Loma sind auch im,
Vorstand, was immer das dann auch äh bedeuten mag und dann gibt es halt noch auf der Webseite so eine eine Liste von Gründungsmitgliedern. Da gehört Björn Böhning dazu, der ja jetzt auch.
Ähm gerade hier in Berlin äh nach der Wahl äh aufgestiegen ist zum Leiter der ähm.
Senatskanzlei, wenn ich das richtig äh erinnere von ähm Herrn Wowereit.
Echt, das waren gar nicht aha, super.
Planungsteam und da hat er jetzt auch noch einen kleinen Karriereboost äh bekommen,
Also von daher auch durchaus schon auch eine einflussreiche äh äh oder einen zunehmenden Maße einflussreiche Persönlichkeit ist. Er war ja auch einer der wenigen bei der SPD, die sich da eigentlich relativ klar.
Gegen Netzsperren in der ganzen Debatte,
positioniert haben, der da auch wirklich so ein einsamer Leuchtturm im im sozialdemokratischen Nebel war und wenig Gehör
fand, aber immerhin nicht aufgehört hat zu blinken. Ja, das kann man ihm sicherlich hoch äh anrechnen. Ja, dann gibt's noch so einige andere,
Personen der Netzgemeinde, deren Namen man sicherlich schon mal.
Mario Sixus zum Beispiel.
Elektrischer Reporter, dann äh Mercedes bunt, die irgendwie früher City Tagesspiegel in der in dem Bereich tätig war und dann zum Guardian.
Genau und das großartige Magazin herausgibt. Mhm.
Irgendwie jetzt gegangen ist da. Ähm also sind auf jeden Fall so äh illustre Personen dabei und dann zum Beispiel auch Stefan Keuchel, Pressesprecher von Google Deutschland.
Tina Kulo, Pressesprecherin von Facebook Deutschland,
und Eva Maria Kirschsipa, die äh so die Lobbyistin für Facebook in Deutschland ist. Ähm da gab's natürlich dann,
auch irgendwie spätestens da gab's dann so Anfragen, was ist das denn da jetzt, was ihr da gemacht habt so, ne, SPD und die ähm Unternehmen, da gab's also einige Blog-Beiträge, die sich da sehr drüber gewundert haben. Äh ich
hatte dann nur irgendwie von Nico Lummer gab's, glaube ich, den Tweet, wo er so sagte, ja, also auch Google Pressesprecher haben ähm.
Freizeit, in der sie sich engagieren können, das wird natürlich dann ähm.
Es wird ja eigentlich wissen, dass das natürlich vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger sein wird, das äh so zu kommunizieren, dass alle das irgendwie sehen.
Ähm bin ich mal sehr gespannt. Also ich verstehe es auch nicht ganz genau, warum sich die da reingeholt haben, weil irgendwie das das da.
Berechtigterweise vielleicht irgendwie Nachfragen kommen würden, war ja irgendwie abzusehen.
Also ich meine, der,
Diese Gruppe nennt sich D vierundsechzig Zentrum für digitalen Fortschritt. Mhm. Ja, ist ja schon ein Statement. Äh.
Nirgendswo lese ich jetzt äh dass es hier um die SPD als solche geht.
Also es gibt hier eine eine nicht zu leugnende SPD durch die Person, aber es ist jetzt ja nicht so, dass man sich aufstellt als expliziter SPD oder so.
Nee, nee, genau, die sagen ja auch, wir sind wir sind irgendwie ähm offen für Mitglieder und so weiter und finde ich auch, also,
Natürlich, Mann, die gehen hin, gründen da ihre Gruppe und dann sind die von mir aus auch alle irgendwie SPD nah und finde ich irgendwie gar nicht so,
Tragisch, ja? Also es wurde ja bei digitaler Gesellschaft, bei der Gründung waren ja dann auch
das war mir gar nicht so bekannt und ich unterschätze auch offensichtlich immer irgendwie diese Partei äh Streitereien, ja. Natürlich waren irgendwie bei digitaler Gesellschaft irgendwie äh oberproportional viele irgendwie Mitglied bei den Grünen,
ja? Was mir irgendwie gar nicht so klar war oder worauf ich irgendwie keinen Wert lege, weil ich ohnehin nicht in irgendeiner Partei sein würde und ähm das jetzt,
Digitale Gesellschaft ist aber nicht äh in keiner Form jetzt irgendwie eine Ding wo irgendwie die grünen Aktien drin hätten. Ja und dann kommen eben hier äh gut dann sind eben viele der Gründungsmitglieder von diesem D vierundsechzig bei der SPD, ja ist dann eben so,
Den Bezug stellen sie auch sofort her, haben ja auch gesagt, wir sind viele in den FAQ steht ja dann auch drin, wir sind viele von uns sind in der SPD und wir haben so ungefähr so eine Ausrichtung, aber ist jetzt nicht irgendwie die ähm die NGO,
Schiene der SPD, die dann auch nebenbei in dem Feld gegründet wurde. Also finde ich, finde ich erstmal ganz okay.
Also man könnte jetzt sagen, eigentlich ist diese D vierundsechzig Initiative so eine so ein ähnlicher Versuch wie auch die digitale Gesellschaft.
Nee, nee, genau. Und das äh da gibt's natürlich schon so einen so einen gewissen Unterschied, also klar irgendwie, die haben,
Hundert Prozent thematische Überschneidung irgendwie, ne, mit äh außer mit nee, nicht hundert Prozent. Äh Transparenz und Open Data, Datenschutz, Netzneutralität Urheberrecht, also alles auch so diese Themen, da werden sie im Zweifelsfall auch eine etwas ähnliche,
Ausrichtung haben,
Äh dann haben sie noch diese Arbeit als Thema mit drin. Da kommt dann vielleicht so ein bisschen das Sozialdemokratische mit rein. Und dieser Ansatz zu sagen, wir sind ein Thinktank, ja, also was was vielleicht diesen Begriff zu klären, was ist ein Thinktank?
Ein Denkpanzer, ja, das ging dann gestern irgendwie oder vorgestern durch den Twitter, ne, der der Denkpanzer rollt jetzt über uns.
Digitale Denkpanzer.
Ähm.
Genau, was also was wir so ein Think Tank machen, ist ja also eigentlich so kommt das ja irgendwie daher, dass irgendwie besonders visionäre und fitte Menschen sich über Probleme, Gedanken machen und Lösungen dafür entwickeln, bevor sie überhaupt akut werden. Also irgendwie so diese gesamte,
ja, der Einzige, der mir jetzt oder der Nächste, der mir da jetzt einfällt, ist irgendwie so dieser so dieses Think Tanks, die schon, weiß ich nicht, vor so und so viel Jahren irgendwie angefangen haben zu sagen, wir müssen hier den Sozialstaat abbauen,
ähm aus welcher Motivation auch immer sie das getan haben. Da gab's eben auch so Think Tanks, die quasi ein.
Problem für die Zukunft gesehen haben oder oder eine Maßnahme für die Zukunft entwickelt haben. Sei jetzt da hingestellt, ob diese Maßnahme notwendig war oder nicht, aber die sich quasi so über die quasi über Weichenstellung in der Zukunft nachdenken, bevor da vielleicht überhaupt,
bevor diese Themen akut werden.
Und ähm es heißt ja glaube ich auch in dem Mission Statement irgendwie ganz schön, dass sie sagen ähm.
Dass es irgendwie bis jetzt keinem gelungen wäre, irgendwie ein komplettes.
Finde ich das jetzt hier, dass sie also so einen kompletten Entwurf für die digitale Gesellschaft gäbe es noch nicht? Und da wollen sie irgendwie.
Da wollen sie sich bemühen, den zu leisten, ja? Und dann irgendwie ähm Veröffentlichung zu machen. Jetzt finde ich das leider nicht. Da gab's doch so einen schönen Text. Da hatte den, der.
Also unter Think Tank verstehe ich auf jeden Fall nochmal ein bisschen was anderes, also sie wollen halt wirklich mehr so Positionspapiere und ähm vielleicht so ein bisschen.
Philosophisch, aber trotzdem konkretere Ansätze irgendwie haben, konkrete Lösungsansätze aus so einer.
Aus so einem Nachdenken. Also so so verstehe ich jetzt irgendwie, was.
Sie sagen ja konkret hier eine Vielzahl von Formaten soll entwickelt werden, Studien, Umfragen, Buchprojekte, journalistische Arbeiten, Diskussionsveranstaltungen,
oder Blogs, Netzwerke, Kampagnenwerkzeuge. Das ist schon ein Unterschied zur digitalen Gesellschaft, die sich ja.
Die Seite habe ich gerade gesucht, ja.
Die sich gerade äh das dieses Mission Statement, dem das zusammengefasst ist.
In dem ja das klingt schon anders als digitale Gesellschaft, die sich ja eigentlich explizit dann auch.
In die politische Arbeit einklinken will, aber jetzt nicht nur so als Vorlagengeber, sondern eben auch wirklich als äh Nachfragenbeantworter.
Ich interpretiere.
Wie gesagt, das da sind die Übergänge natürlich auch fließend und ähm ja, also,
Man hat ja, glaube ich, gesehen, jeder freut sich irgendwie, dass es das gibt. Ich bin ja eh immer auf dem Standpunkt zu sagen, wir brauchen mehr,
Gruppierungen, die sich in dem Bereich engagieren und jetzt werden wir mal sehen, wann da jetzt in Facebook und Google drin sitzen
Wie gesagt, da sind sehr viele Leute irgendwie relativ skeptisch gewesen. Ich persönlich verstehe jetzt nicht genau, warum das der Fall ist. Aber ich sehe da jetzt,
keine Veranlassung irgendwie groß rum zu.
Ich finde es, ich finde das ein bisschen,
Jetzt ein bisschen überzogen zu sagen, da sitzen jetzt Facebook und Google drin. Nur weil es zwei oder drei Gründungsmitglieder gibt, die einen Job da haben.
Ja, ich meine, deren Job ist halt zuständig für Privatsphäre sein, et cetera,
In Ordnung, ja, ich meine, das ist ja nicht so, nur, weil man jetzt da arbeitet, dass man dann sich nicht mehr politisch einbringen soll, gerade äh vor dem Hinblick, dass das ja auch durchaus eine eine Tätigkeit ist, wo man eben mit diesen Fragen auch permanent,
in Berührung kommt, also gar nicht mal jetzt nur im Sinne von was ist das Interesse meiner Firma, für die ich arbeite, sondern es ist ja auch einfach wenn man eben so einen Job macht, dann hat man einfach eine ganz andere äh Auseinandersetzung mit diesen Themenbereichen und das,
das kann man ja auch positiv sehen, dass man sich dann eben auch einbringen. Wir können ja auch sagen, ach Politik ist mir auch scheißegal. Ich mache hier irgendwie Privatsphäre äh für Google.
Da sind ja auch genug andere Leute drin, als dass äh es jetzt irgendwie zu befürchten wäre, dass dass Facebook und Google da jetzt irgendwie Astrid Turfing über diesen D vierundsechzig äh.
Sie sehen, die Frage ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen, wer wer sozusagen diese Personen äh äh sein und äh
wann entscheiden diese Personen, die sich jetzt da äh ins Licht der Öffentlich äh haben stellen lassen, dann auch als D vierundsechzig aktiv zu werden, ja.
Wird es einen Sprecher geben, äh wird es äh da so ein so einen Kreis von Leuten geben, die dann
da sind oder sind das wurde jetzt hier nur die Standard-Panelbesetzung für alle kommenden Veranstaltungen bekannt gegeben, ja? Das könnte ja auch durchaus sein, das ist dann wieder so eine,
Show, der der immer gleichen äh gibt. Hier muss man, glaube ich, abwarten.
Vielleicht noch ganz kurz äh
was ich gerade noch zum Matthias Richie gesagt habe, der wird hier auch in einem Artikel von dem von mir sehr geschätzten Kai Biermann auf Zeit online zitiert, wo er sagt, doch die Partei von innen verändern zu wollen, funktioniert nicht, sagt Matthias Richel, der Vorsitzende, man müsse von außen auf sie einwirken, wenn man etwas
etwas erreicht werden soll, also dass er tatsächlich irgendwie so ein ähm.
Das sieht man so in seiner Arbeit, dass er das irgendwie macht. Und dann gab's hier auch noch in diesem Artikel so einen Vergleich mit äh.
Verein digitale Gesellschaft. Ähm oder was was Kai hier so,
Er schreibt fehlt eigentlich nur noch der Blogger Sascha Lovo, der ist erstaunlicherweise nicht dabei, bislang, zumindest sonst aber fast jeder, der im und durch das Netz sein Geld verdient und irgendetwas mit den Sozialdemokraten zu tun hat. Auch Mitglieder der Partei gehören dazu.
Und ähm ich also er sagte.
Ach Mann, wo steht denn das hier? Ach, auf Seite zwei des Artikels. Da stand irgendwie so ungefähr drin, dass das von diesem D vierundsechzig vielleicht eine nicht ganz so radikale
zu erwarten, weil oder nicht ganz so kompromisslose Position zu erwarten wären, wie von äh digitale Gesellschaft, die im Zweifelsfall schon eher eine Maximalposition vertreten,
die selbst Wahrnehmung eben als.
Als kompromissloser Lobbyist für die Bürgerrechte und bei bei einem vielleicht so ein bisschen näherer Bezug zu.
Zur Realität.
Das hast du jetzt gesagt.
Oder zum politischen Pragmatismus.
Genau, also so ein.
Ich scherze nur.
Verstehe denn das hier?
Ach Mann, ich find's jetzt nicht, aber den Artikel verlinken wir sehr schön beschrieben und ja, herzlich willkommen, D vierundsechzig und ähm
bin mal sehr gespannt, was da läuft, was da so kommt und wird auf jeden Fall spannend sein und gerade die SPD hat ja durchaus Bedarf, dass es da vielleicht irgendwie.
Solche Bezüge gibt.
Vierundsechzig, ja äh lustiger Name, sie greifen ja im Prinzip diesen Artikel, den schon mittlerweile muss man ihn ja jetzt schon fast als legendär bezeichnen, ne, von äh Christian Stücker auf, den er mal bei äh Spiegel Online veröffentlicht hat,
diesen Namen Generationen vierundsechzig oder Generation C vierundsechzig äh überhaupt erst geboren hat so,
Lustigerweise hat Mario ja auch schon bekannt gegeben, dass sein erster Computer gar nicht C vierundsechzig war. Ich habe mich jetzt auch gefragt, ob das irgendwie hier alle einen Zeh finden mitm C vierundsechzig gestartet sein müssen oder ob das sowieso jetzt nur äh so einen Club, der äh Achtziger ist, so
ja, also wenn man seine Jugend nicht in der Nacht
Jahren gehabt hat und von dem ganzen Kram sozialisiert wurde, so darf man dann nicht mitmachen oder äh gilt man dann schon wieder als zu zu jung oder zu alt?
Ja und was ist, wenn man andere Computer toll fand? Also ich habe zwar beim C vierundsechzig angefangen, aber ich glaube, ich werde da jetzt erstmal nicht eintreten.
Ja, wer also ich ich bin da auf jeden Fall mal sehr gespannt, wie das so läuft, ne. Sind ja irgendwie ähm also ich bin einfach mal sehr gespannt, was da.
Ja, ich meine, gerade im Hinblick, ich meine wenn sie nur ein bisschen was von dem wahrmachen, was sie hier ankündigen, ähm können wir uns auf weitere Termine freuen, ja. Meine Buchprojekte,
Studien, Umfragen, journalistische Arbeiten, Diskussionsveranstaltungen, das ist schon.
Viel Spaß, Freunde.
Ist ist eine Menge, ne? Da bin ich äh dann gespannt, ne. Ich hoffe, es ist mehr als nur Panel bla.
Ja da also ich bin auf jeden Fall mal sehr gespannt und ähm wahrscheinlich so wie ich den ähm Matthias Richel kenne, wird er nicht nur die Gründung aufm Schirm gehabt haben, das heißt, ich gehe ehrlich gesagt davon aus, dass man von denen relativ bald was hören wird,
werden wahrscheinlich schon ein ein Schritt weiter geplant haben, was als nächstes von diese von diesem Club kommen wird. Da bin ich mir relativ sicher,
ohne ihn jetzt besonders gut zu kennen, weiß ich aber, dass er sich über solche Gedanken, solche Dinge richtig Gedanken macht, weil das sein Job ist und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass von denen bald äh was zu hören sein wird.
Das Timing der Bekanntgabe wiederum äh riecht natürlich extrem danach,
dass hier äh schon auf diesen SPD-Parteitag in irgendeiner Form eingewirkt werden soll. Das ist jetzt
mal so eine Unterstellung äh von mir, aber man hätt's ja auch später machen können. Sicherlich wollte man sich da auch im Rahmen des SPD-Parteitags zumindest schon mal ins Gespräch bringen, ja? Was äh
vielleicht auch gelungen sein wird, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung, vielleicht äh reden auch alle nur von Helmut Schmidt, weiß man nicht. Ähm auf jeden Fall ähm.
Stand nun der SPD Parteitag an,
hat jetzt auch schon soweit erstmal äh stattgefunden an diesem Wochenende, geht aber heute wohl noch weiter und leider, leider, leider kam es jetzt bei der äh
von uns äh zuletzt auch angesprochenen Problematik der Entschlussfindung um die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zum Zeitpunkt dieses Gesprächs hier,
noch nicht zu einer Abstimmung. Das wurde vertagt auf den im Montag, der jetzt hier gerade läuft. Von daher wissen wir jetzt nicht, wie's ausgegangen ist. Es gab aber eine,
ja ein Komp ein Kompromissdokument zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Genau, es tauchte irgendwie, dass das tauchte irgendwie dann gestern, war das auf einmal im Twitter? Ich glaube, vom Jan Mönies war, glaube ich, der ursprüngliche Tweet und
dann auch auf äh dem Netzpolitikblog, also dem dem äh SPD-Netzpolitik DE, Blog von einigen engagierten sozialdemokratischen Netzpolitikern und da kam eben so ein.
Äh kam dieser Kompromisstext irgendwie erst als irgendwie so Foto-Tweets und so und ähm
Da wird also gesagt, äh drei Monate Laufzeit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung und äh darin soll festgelegt werden, dass die Daten für Bagatellfälle wie Urheberrechtsverletzungen oder die oder
beziehungsweise sowie zur Erstellung von Bewegungsprofilen nicht genutzt werden können. Und.
Das ist natürlich jetzt so eine Frage, so das Problem ist natürlich dann oder was, was ja, sage ich mal, alle Vorratsanspeicherungsgegner in so einem Fall sagen, ist, dass sie sagen, naja, wenn ihr
überwacht ihr baut dann trotzdem diese Überwachungsstruktur auf, ja? Und als nächstes ähm,
ist dann eben der Dammbruch, um diese Daten auch noch zu nutzen, das ist dann eben der ist dann irgendwie
umso kleiner, ja, da braucht ihr nur nochmal einer von der CDU hinzugehen und das äh äh das traurige Lied zu singen, dass diese Daten ja da sind und die armen den armen Polizisten sind die Hände gebunden und sie müssen ja nicht drauf zugreifen können. Und dann haben wir
genau dieses Problem, dass irgendwie zu jedem zu jeder Kleinigkeit auf diese Daten zugegriffen wird und das irgendwie so ein Massenphänomen ist in diese Vorwasseranspeichungsdaten.
Es scheint ja auch schon so ein Schönheitswettbewerb hier äh ausgerufen worden zu sein. Wer denn jetzt äh die die die schickste Verkürzung äh dieser,
Periode da, der der Datenspeicherung bekannt gibt, ja, also,
Von der CDU, weil es mittlerweile auch schon mit vier Monaten glücklich und ich meine, klar, wahrscheinlich würden sie sich auch auf einen Monat einigen,
Hauptsache, es wird überhaupt erstmal gespeichert, weil wir wissen alle, in dem Moment, wo das dann aktiv ist, dann dauert das noch zwei, drei Jahre,
Und dann gibt's so diese Fälle mit, ja, jetzt waren die Daten gerade weg und äh hätten wir nur und,
ja und äh warum denn nicht? Und dann wird das halt irgendwie einfach mal so nebenbei dann auf sechs Monate oder auf zwölf Monate oder auf was weiß ich, erhöht und dann tritt einfach genau das ein.
Ja, das ist dann so unter ferner liefen, kann man dann noch so schnell nochmal eben die Frist verlängern und.
Genau, so, weil dann wird's dann wird sich auch keiner mehr groß dagegen wehren können und äh von daher ist es natürlich jetzt schon bezeichnend, dass es der SPD offensichtlich nicht äh gelungen zu sein scheint, sich hier mit einer Maximalforderung durchzusetzen.
Was eben insbesondere so blöd ist, weil die SPD ja noch so ein bisschen Volkspartei sein könnte, ja? Und äh wenn
wenn sie dann irgendwie, sagen wir mal, in der Opposition ist jetzt gerade und dann irgendwie letztendlich nur noch Nuancen sich von der Forderung
Regierung irgendwie entfernt und dann eigentlich letztendlich die FDP es ist an der es hängt, ja, dass dass
nicht kommt, dann äh werden natürlich zu Recht äh die Leute die Bürgerrechtler und Schweigerungsgegner äh nervös.
Ja klar, weil das könnte ja durchaus bei der nächsten Wahl auf eine große Koalition hinauslaufen und dann wär's ja klar, wie da so die Gemengelage ist. Tja, wer hat denn jetzt diesen Kompromiss überhaupt ausgehandelt.
Weiß ich nämlich nicht. Da habe ich deswegen wollte ich ja heute irgendwie noch, habe ich ja gehofft, dass da noch mehr Informationen kommen. Also er wurde anscheinend
kam er aus dem aus der Feder der Antragskommission, kann ja nur von denen kommen. Also Antragskommission schlägt ja vor, worüber irgendwie verhandelt wird. Und anscheinend hat die Antragskommission
irgendwie in relativ kurzfristig dann eben diesen einen Antrag da noch zu einem Kompromiss verändert. Das mehr weiß ich nicht.
Das Beste, was passieren könnte, ist, dass er einfach abgelehnt wird. So. Meine, was bedeutet das dann?
Bleibt die SPD bei ihrer bis dahin gültigen Position hat da gar keiner oder hätte da gar keinen Entschluss zu.
Beste wäre, wenn sie von vorneherein die neuen Anträge oder wie viele das waren zur Abschaffung, einen davon durchgelassen hätten. Ja, das wäre natürlich sehr schön gewesen. Dann äh
jetzt irgendwie diese Debatte nicht. Ich bin mal, also ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wie das jetzt da so wie das so weiterläuft.
Wir werden's ja heute dann erfahren und beim nächsten Logbuchnetzpolitik noch kurz durcheiern, ja.
Durcheiern. Genau.
Noch ein letztes Thema. Ich sehe, wir sind jetzt so bei fünfundvierzig, sechsundvierzig Minuten. Sollen wir das trotzdem noch schnell reinnehmen?
Klar. Ja. Das machen wir jetzt auch noch zu Ende. Ist halt jetzt eine sehr äh ereignisreiche äh Woche. Da das war halt hier auch ein bisschen zeitlich bluten. Aber die Stunde reißen wir nicht.
Genau, also das, das ist ja nur ein kleines Impulsreferat von mir jetzt, äh netzsperren, Aufhebung wurde am ersten Dezember beschlossen. Ähm wir hatten ja bis dahin
tatsächlich in in offizieller Gültigkeit hatten wir ja netzsperren in Deutschland. Sie kamen nur nicht zur Anwendung. Es ging irgendwie am siebzehnten April zweitausendneun ging das irgendwie los, dass die Bundesregierung so einen Vertrag mit,
fünf großen Internet Providern über bestimmte Sperren hatte. Äh achtundzwanzigster Juni zweitausendneun wurde das dann,
tatsächlich auch als Gesetz beschlossen, dass wir so eine DNS-Sper Infrastruktur haben wollen, dass ja alles jetzt irgendwie sehr verbunden mit äh den Namen ähm Schäuble und insbesondere Ursula von der Leyen.
Ähm.
Susela vorever, das ist also den Namen verzehr ich nicht mehr los.
So, dann hatten sie es im Juni beschlossen, zweitausend Oktober sagte dann schon Schäuble, ja, das Ding hatte irgendwie handwerkliche Fehler, das wollten wir noch schnell im Wahlkampfstress durchpressen,
auch so eine schöne, so eine schöne Sache war, ne? Das, also du hattest das ja, glaube ich, beim letzten Mal schon angesprochen, dass die da damals dachten, so, Mensch, super, kommen hier die. Von der Leyen, die prescht jetzt nochmal kurz hier mit Kinderpornografie vor, der kann nicht schiefgehen.
Verweigerte Horst Köhler zunächst die Unterschrift unter dieses Gesetz und irgendwie keiner wollte es mehr, die SPD, die IS mit dafür gestimmt hat, hat sich dann auch irgendwie im Laufe der Zeit äh anders überlegt,
und sich dann irgendwie gegen ihr eigenes Gesetz positioniert, dann hatte im Februar zweitausendelf Köder das dann doch unterschrieben.
Und da gab's dann irgendwie schon die Hoffnung, ähm dass das oder zeichnete sich schon ab. Er konnte ja im Prinzip nur,
Also in dem Moment, erstens war das Problem, also es wurde dann davon ausgegangen, dass er damit die die quasi die Chance geben will, ein Aufregerhebungsgesetz zu machen.
Dass also in dieser Schwebe, dass er es nicht, wenn er es erstmal unterschrieben, solange er es nicht unterschrieben hatte, konnte eigentlich auch keiner was dagegen machen.
Nicht dagegen klagen. In dem Moment wäre er dann unterschrieben hatte, konnte man dagegen klagen, aber irgendwie drei Tage, nachdem er's unterschrieben hat, gab es dann auch vom äh Innenministerium den Erlass
Schwerlisten nicht zu machen. Und dann wurde eine Verfassungsbeschwerde angestrengt, die wurde aber nicht zugelassen, weil sie unzureichend begründet wurde.
Oder weil sie angeblich unzurechnen begründet war. Und dann hatten wir diese schöne Zeit oder diese schöne Situation, dass es ein Gesetz gab, was aber per Erlass nicht,
Ähm umgesetzt wurde. Und da gab's ja dann auch immer diese schönen Artikel von den ganzen äh Juristen und und äh Verfassungsrichtern, die alle sagten, so was gab's eigentlich noch nie, dass irgendwie die Bundesregierung äh äh ein Gesetz äh macht äh äh,
Präsident unterschreibt das und dann äh.
Ja, nee, das fanden wir jetzt nicht so gut. So, das äh machen wir jetzt mal nicht.
Ja genau, dann äh dann war äh war's aber sowieso zeitlich befristet bis zweitausendzwölf und dann ging ja diese ganzen ähm.
Dann gingen ja diese ganzen Anhörungen los, wo dann irgendwie im Bundestag dann der irgendwie, also mit dieser BMI,
mit diesem BMI-Erlass ging ja einher, dass sie löschen statt Sperren versuchen sollen, ja? Und dann also quasi,
Serverbetreiber ansprechen und irgendwie darauf hinwirken, dass da tatsächlich dann auch eine Strafverfolgung gemacht wird, statt nur irgendwie ein Stoffschild davor zu hängen, was jeder,
halbwegs begabte Internetnutzer umgehen kann und was eben die Täter warnen würde, wenn dann dass man sieht, okay, die sind jetzt auf uns aufmerksam geworden.
Und eben die Kollateralschäden haben, könnte und so weiter. Dann gab's aber so schöne Anhörungen irgendwie im im Bundestag noch, wo dann der Zirkel eben dann auch da irgendwie erzählt, ja, das mit dem Löschen statt Sperren klappt irgendwie alles nicht und dann wurde die Interpretation dann irgendwie von anderen,
angezweifelt und da wurde irgendwie gesagt, na ja klar ich meine der Zirke will ganz offensichtlich die,
die Netzsperren haben, ist ja klar, wenn er jetzt irgendwie angewiesen wird, den Bedarf zu prüfen,
in seinen Ergebnissen haben könnte, war alles ganz wild. April zweitausendelf hat dann die äh FDP einen Entwurf für einen Aufhebungsgesetz ins Rollen gebracht.
Der wurde dann schon im Mai zweitausendelf im Kabinett zum Gesetzesentwurf. Ja und jetzt am ersten Zwölften hat der Bundestag darüber entschieden, das war, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, eine sehr glatte Abstimmung. Hatten alle irgendwie eingesehen. Netzsperren wieder vom Tisch.
Wollte sich jetzt auch echt, kann er mir den Schuh anziehen.
Wollte, also die Zensursula wollte sich irgendwie keiner mehr geben.
Und ähm ja, gab's also glaube ich ähm gab's einige Pressemitteilungen, die ich auch mal für die für die Shownotes mit aufgenommen habe.
Ähm dass das, dass man sich da vielleicht jetzt doch mal auf die Schulter klopfen kann, weil wenn man sich das überlegt, wie wie.
Perfekt diese Nummer eigentlich durchgeplant war und wie unbezwingbar dieser Gegner äh Kinderpornografie als Argument, diese die, wie wird das immer genannt, die Kipo-Keule,
wie wie krass dieses Argument wiegen kann in so einer Debatte, dass dann da die.
Ja, die netzpolitische Bewegung, Bürgerrechtsbewegung, wer auch immer in ganz vielen verschiedenen Vereinen, Formationen und Aktionen es geschafft hat, sich dagegen zur Wehr zu setzen. Da kann man, glaube ich, echt mal.
Kann man jetzt erstmal können eine ganze Menge Gruppierungen, ganze Menge Akteure und deswegen nenne ich jetzt niemanden. Können sich da echt auf die Schulter klopfen.
Ja, das war schon echt erstaunlich. So und vor allem dadurch, dass jetzt auch wirklich ein Punkt gesetzt worden, wo man sagen kann, das hatte alles eine,
Ergebnis, also dieser ganze Widerstand hat sich einfach extrem gelohnt, da hat sich die Politik,
Eine furchtbar blutige Nase geholt. Also allein diese Tatsache, diese diese Peinlichkeit, dass man eigentlich in jeder Hinsicht gegen die Verfassung verstößt,
Hinzu, wir erlassen ein Gesetz und führen's da nicht durch, was ja auch nochmal die juristische Fragen aufwirft ohne Ende, ja. Das ist ja eigentlich ein vollkommen unhaltbarer Zustand. Man fragt sich, was,
sinnvollen Gesetzen, wo es eine breite Unterstützung in der Bevölkerung gibt, äh was was man denn dann davon halten würde, dass man so einen Erlass macht, so. Ja, na ja, das ist ja jetzt ganz schön so, aber ähm.
Wir haben uns halt anders überlegt.
Durchsetzen wollen wir das jetzt mal nicht so. Ja, ist doch schön, wenn's auf dem Papier steht,
Also es ist wirklich verfahren, ne? Und äh das hat schon so seine äh Auswirkungen gehabt und ich habe den Eindruck, jetzt nach diesen zwei Jahren.
Auch wenn man jetzt mal alles so Revue passieren lässt, was wir jetzt in diesem Podcast gerade gesagt haben, ja, mit D vierundsechzig und Piratenpartei und und so weiter und den Auswirkungen auf die SPD. Äh,
Es ist jetzt einfach deutlich ablesbar. Er hat's äh ist tatsächlich das einundzwanzigste Jahrhundert, ist jetzt auf der Agenda, ich will jetzt gar nicht mal nur Internet sagen, aber es ist wirklich, dass äh da auch eine neue Generation,
Ob sie nun mit dem C vierundsechzig, dem Amiga oder meinetwegen auch erst mit Windows geboren wurde, ist vollkommen egal. Äh eine eine Generation, die einfach ein äh eine andere gesellschaftliche Realität,
zur Kenntnis genommen hat, so in ihrem Leben, als die, die eben vorher geherrscht hat, äh
unter anderem eben unter Nutzung digitaler Netzwerke, aber nicht nur das, dass die jetzt so langsam,
Zuge kommt, dass es jetzt einfach wirklich auch ein ein Zeitenwandel ist, der sich natürlich langsam vollzieht, aber der jetzt einfach sichtbar wird, dass er sich vollzieht.
Also ganz klar und also,
ja, wie wir das jetzt hier sehen, so die Parteien sind, also alle Parteien sind irgendwie von diesem Thema aufgescheucht, ja und irgendwie es ist ja nicht nur Netzsperren, sondern Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben sie sich ja auch schon damals ihre Nase äh abgeholt, ja, also das äh,
Und da sieht man ja jetzt auch bei, ja, was dieses, inzwischen wahrscheinlich etwas abgedroschene Beispiel, Peter Altmaier twittert jetzt, ja. Äh,
Gut, da will ich jetzt nicht viel mehr will ich da nicht zu sagen, ja, aber ja, dass, dass ich meine, das wahrscheinlich schon sieht man, wie scheu die Pferde inzwischen sind.
Ja gut, aber twitternde Politiker allein, äh das hilft jetzt noch nicht, ne? Aber ähm zumindest wird es wird das jetzt alles ernst genommen und man macht sich darüber seine Gedanken und das kann natürlich schon eine Basis äh sein.
Haben wir jetzt noch Themen, die wir nicht in die nächste Woche verschieben können?
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Also vielleicht Ausblick auf nächste Woche, wer den Podcast heute noch hört, Julian Assange, heute die Anhörung,
oder was heißt die, also die Anhörung, bei der entschieden wird, ob über seinen Fall entschieden werden soll,
oder ob er auf die Reise geht und eventuell würde er dann schon, weil das ja dann vierzehn Tage sind, wäre der neunzehnte Zwölfte der letzte Zeitpunkt für ihn äh in den Flieger nach Schweden zu steigen.
Wenn das heute die Entscheidung wird heute getroffen, dann gab's von dieses Beifalls, das ist aber eigentlich ein das ist kalter Kaffee
Das sind ja nur, also eigentlich aus vielen Quellen, die auch schon vorher online waren, zusammengetragen. Diese hauptsächlich Werbematerialien von irgendwelchen,
ähm Überwachungsunternehmen, also habe ich auch zu Hause rum.
Also da nehmen die Überwachungstechnologie herstellen und die ja dann auch in fragwürdige äh Länder exportiert wird.
Genau. Also ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante Ressource, die da mal
hergestellt wurde. War ja aber vorher auch schon im Wall Street Journal so eine Zusammenfassung und äh dann gibt's noch dieses Back
Planet Punkt Info, das hat der nicht äh das also auch so eine Übersichtsseite dazu, die wende ich mich nicht täusche von Andy Müller Magun zusammengestellt wurde, der sich ja für solche Themen auch seit jeher,
interessiert war ganz spannend. Oder also war mal ganz nett so das zu haben, aber war jetzt nicht irgendwie das große Mordsleague.
Und dann gab's den Leitfaden zum Datenzugriff, der irgendwie ähm,
veröffentlicht wurde vom AK Vorrat und da würde ich aber jetzt einfach mal sagen, da haben wir ähm ein paar Blogbeiträge verlinkt unter.
Unserem Podcast und verweisen einfach mal auf die.
Genau. Logbuch Schrägnetzpolitik Punkt DE,
findet ihr immer ausführliche Shownotes. Wer also das hier alles immer nur Audiofilm wahrnimmt, da kann man sich einbringen. Wir freuen uns auch sehr über ähm Kommentare, ein bisschen Feedback
Könnt ihr mal ruhig äh geben jetzt nach sechsten Sendung. Würden uns auch mal ein paar,
Anmerkungen ganz äh gut tun, wie ihr das Angebot so äh findet,
Wir machen jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal weiter. Das ist nicht der Punkt, aber äh immer äh äh auch gut so äh andere Meinungen zu hören über das, was man so tut und lässt.
Nicht wahr? Ja. Und ansonsten geht's nächste Woche weiter.
Genau. Nächste Woche geht's weiter.
So sieht's aus. Bis bald. Tschau, tschau.
Bis dahin. Ciao, ciao.